why can I come into McDonald's because
I'm wearing a shed I'm sorry but like
can you please say it it's not just a
matter of taking it off I read this for
religious reasons and I'm not ashamed of
it
and I will stand in line and I will get
the food that I want because this isn't
okay
I literally live down the street from
here this is actually like a hate crime
this is a hate crime
thank you I'm sorry but I just want to
know who's implementing this policy
because particular flight I'm just like
so shocked right now I've been living in
the UK for 19 years now and this is the
first time I'm faced with this kind of
discrimination and I am shocked I don't
want anything anymore I'm pretty full to
them to the head
on to the tunnel these two lovely people
I'm just telling people that you guys
are helping us but wasn't he at listen
charlie and Charlie Charlie awesome
Arsenal fans there are hundreds and born
under Bruce yet we was a bit lost but
Holloway world was close but Charlie and
his wife yeah hope you treat her well
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday there was an incident before
yesterday that guy has been there has
been telling by security people
none of the company is dealing with them
this is working for security department
so two security beginning within the
security gone wheel company we've been
in front of company company so that's
we're in front of this McDonald's in
Seven Sisters Road as you guys know
about yeah a day or two days ago which
the footage you saw assist a security
guard was asking a sister who was just
casually walking in a regular customer
to take off her hijab because of a
security reason now where is this
stemming from this is stemming from
bigots and Islamophobe in the stomach
folk group and individuals like Tony
Robinson brain first K Hopson K Hopkins
and many other individuals who are
pushing this agenda out and trying to
put fear into the people's heart and
getting the genuine concern of the
British public and using that to vilify
the Muslims and this is also stemming
from Ofsted starting this whole campaign
of oh we're gonna question Muslim girls
of why they were in hijab why is the
same lot being done to the Jewish
community in stamford deal where I live
very closely where the Jewish community
have their own school segregated and
children are totally dressed up in a
certain way does Ofsted go and do the
same thing to them no they don't
so this is where this bigotry and this
hatred is rising so much that you have a
security guard who is in minority
himself or pressing another minority
besides the point now why I wanna say is
something really important firstly who
the flipper who the hell comes to
McDonald's for food it's disgusting it's
junk food seriously we need to change
our diet and I'm going to say this to
the sister I'm just talking in general
why the hell would you eat this junk
food it's absolute disgusting we need
some avocado and some nice organic foods
in our life that's point one yeah I just
wanted to mention that weari need to
change our diet disgusting food I'm
sorry no offense here it's just rubbish
now secondly to Muslim out there
to see this black security guard doing
this action you guys are as ignorant as
the guy who does it for you some of you
guys who are using racial slurs against
the guy there's this stamp teach this
does it teach that oh he's done
something wrong I know we'll get him
back because of his skin color the one
of the biggest one of the greatest
Sahaba was Bernard on the other hand so
please fix up
point number three guys what you need to
understand is Allah has honored the
Muslims with the Quran and the Sunnah
yeah and the seller following the
Sullivans the Quran has exalted Muslims
by following the Quran and the Sunnah
now the thing here is this we have
turned our back against the Quran and
Sunnah the real teaching not what these
extremists do running over innocent
people know the true Quran and Sunna
which says respect other people and live
in peace with other people this what
understand about use turned your back on
and believe me brother sisters we will
continue being humiliated as long as we
do not change our attitude and turn back
to our religion to Allah and the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him to the Quran
and Sunnah we are going to be humiliated
over and over again so do not think
doing protests going around shouting
doing this that are yes these videos are
there to raise awareness however the
truth the truth success lies who are
following the Quran and the Sunnah we
need to turn back to our religion and
peacefully and live amongst our non
Muslim brothers and sisters in humanity
this is really important so I wanted to
say and please boycott his mcdonough
smell disgusting food